my compadre my friend from nbc sports
right here on nbc sports on peacock
his football morning in america column
every monday is must-read material
including this monday he is peter king
how are you peter
rich how's it going with you i am better
for talking to you because it's draft
month peter i'm so excited this is so
exciting i i
i know that you know number one is not
much of a of a of a question and number
two is the jets
so there's always going to be a question
until we actually hear it and then when
we hear it we'll wonder if that was the
right move
and then what the niners did at three
i'm i'm very excited about this
draft peter what do you think well i
think
one of the reasons you should be excited
is that
you know i think there's three story
lines right at the top
um i had a coach tell me last week he
said i've never seen
uh i've never seen quarterbacks get
pushed up the board
as aggressively as they're getting
pushed up the board this year
where there's a real legitimate chance
that the top four picks are quarterbacks
and and as as another uh gm
told me that
other than trevor lawrence at least on
their board
uh after trevor lawrence
there are six players before any other
quarterback comes into play and yet
it could well be that the top four picks
could be quarterbacks this year that
means like if you're the new york giants
you know you might get a great
potentially a great
tackle just drop into your lap at number
11
you know or if you're the dallas cowboys
who really need to start rebuilding that
offensive line
i mean they have a lot of needs but they
there are just so many interesting
possibilities
based on the quality and the caliber of
players
that are going to drop and then i think
the last thing is
what's the team right now is it carolina
at eight is it new england at 15
or ia or is it somebody else that i'm
not even thinking of maybe chicago at
twenty
what team is going to perhaps
irrationally move up to try to get
say the fifth quarterback or you know if
they're in love with the fourth
quarterback whoever it is
you know move up and maybe pay too much
i mean i
rich the question is and you're you're
mr jet
what happens if and look we can we've
all said
it looks like kyle wilson's going number
two and i
do believe that that is by far
it has the best chance of happening so
what happens if they
yeah if they if they keep sam darnold
and they trade and get carolinas one
in they trade down to eight and they get
carolina's one in
22 and one in 23 and and they have sam
darnold for one more year
and they then put off their quarterback
choice until next year the year after
i think it's i hey look i don't know
what's going to happen
but the jets really intrigue me in this
draft well the whole reason why i would
think that the jets wouldn't trade down
um if this is true
is that the you know the 49ers
either a offered the same thing to the
jets and they turned it down or
remarkably did not even knock on the
jets door
potentially i think they did knock on
the jets door and i think joe douglas
i wrote a couple of weeks ago said that
uh we're not trading the pick
and so um if if that is true
if that's true then jets are gonna sit
there and they're gonna pick somebody i
doubt they're gonna sit at two
and take kyle pitts you know even though
it might be
even though if if sam darnold stayed uh
i bet he'd be pretty happy to have kyle
pitts on his team well if sam darnold
stayed they wouldn't be choosing second
overall either right because it would
have been right they wouldn't get it
worked out
unless right rich what what what what
happens if they trade down and
somehow some way because look i'm not
saying it's probable or
or anything but if you trade to eight
one of those receivers
or kyle pitts is going to be sitting
there
and maybe two uh so
you just you never know what might
happen yeah i don't know
uh peter it's just again when you see
the
the wide receivers in this league who
have been so successful from
dk metcalf to justin jefferson to tyreek
hill
and how they're all none of them are top
15 you know like
to to actually sit here and stick with
the quarterback
that could be very talented you know
still and sam darnold because he he's on
he's been unfairly evaluated there's no
two ways about that
but to bring in a new regime and
and tell them you need to evaluate this
kid
too after that would make a third
different regime
evaluating sam darnold as opposed to
just starting the clock
fresh which we all know contractually
what that means in terms of salary cap
and then you know i i don't i don't see
sticking with sam darnold being a viable
option
for a team that just doesn't want to
keep choosing you know top three top
four or or hope that the first rounders
that they get
are are at the top of the draft it's
time to actually start
hitting the win it now button don't you
think yeah peter i agree
but rich if you if you trade sam darnold
and you pick zach wilson
you're not winning big this year you
know you're still building
and so and you know you made a great
point about receivers
does anybody remember that just four
years ago
the fifth seventh and ninth picks in the
draft were corey davis mike williams and
john ross there you go
i mean john ross is already washout mike
williams
is good he's not a big star uh corey
davis
is on the chats it's pretty good and now
he's a jet
so i i i again i could not
agree with you more because last year
i thought uh when i look back on the
draft last year
uh the best pick in the draft would just
was justin jefferson being picked number
22.
and you know so to me you just
i think the wide receiver classes now
are so good so deep
that if you can get chase claypool at i
think he was
49 you know if and if
if you can get look i mean tyler johnson
i think is going to be a really good
player for the bucks he's a fifth round
pick
and it isn't just last year it's uh
obviously the year before
after pick number 50 you know
aj brown dk metcalf terry mclaurin
i mean i i would i i look at wide
receivers today like i look at running
backs you you can
you can get one down the line peter king
here on the rich eisen show
what are the niners doing at three what
do they do to get up there for who
they they must have somebody in mind
clearly
they're they're not going to evaluate
everybody not name trevor lawrence or
zack wilson just because right they they
must
well have actually identified i honestly
take john lynch
as word uh when he says
that we haven't decided firmly who we're
taking
at number three uh but
we now know that we can get a
quarterback
uh who we can build around uh for the
future because we like
uh all three couple of quarterbacks i
mean you know
okay so and so and so and and and
and the other the other point i would
make and i wrote about this today in my
column
is that i really don't think jimmy
garoppolo is going anywhere
in in part because if you're a team
and you wanted to trade for jimmy
garoppolo do you want to trade for a guy
who's missed 23 games in the last three
years and who makes 24 million dollars
and you really don't know if he can stay
healthy and they want to win for him
do you really want to do that i don't i
want to wait until
march when jimmy garoppolo just might i
doubt it but
might be on the street you know and
and so i i would i would much rather
keep garoppolo if i'm the 49ers
and i think they will and garoppolo goes
into camp as the starter
and he's got an apprentice who maybe
he's not going to actually tutor and
help the way
josh mccown would but he's going to have
a guy
trailing him and uh whether it's mac
jones or or trey lance or or whoever it
is
justin fields we'll see but i think the
49ers
if i had to guess right now i guess they
would take mac jones there
but that's all it is right now and i
think they're
i i believe when they made this trade
they did not
know for sure they might have feelings
about which one they
they wanted if zach wilson goes to
but i don't think i think that is still
uh
a tbd no i and i know jed york loves his
management team and why not
right and kyle shanahan um
you know uh clearly has an idea about
his
system and who would work well in it but
i know if i'm jed
i'm like so you want to trade all that
for just still evaluating like
hey you sure we're good with everybody i
mean so
rich isn't it isn't it possible that
that john lynch could have asked kyle
shanahan this question
all right kyle uh you know
trevor lawrence is out zach wilson
probably is out right i want to know
of the other three quarterbacks or
however many there are
you know who could go very high in this
draft
is there somebody here who absolutely
categorically
you would want to be your quarterback
for the next 10 years
and kyle shanahan i would bet looked him
in the eye and said
yes without any question why does he
have to pick him right now
if he if he's looked at the tape and
he wants to study let's say trey lance a
little bit more because he's only played
one game in the last 400 days
but but again again i don't think it's
ridiculous at all i think the one thing
though if you're the 49ers
you have looked at this thing and you
realize that without
a full-time quarterback a you know
a a garoppolo or better starter
in the four seasons you've had one
really good year
and the other three years you've won six
six and four games
so you know i i think it would be
foolhardy honestly to trade garoppolo
unless
of course they got a a ridiculous offer
which i don't think they'll get
peter king here on the rich eisen show
another uh item in your in your column
was uh
about justin fields and you know it's
entirely pop i mean everyone went crazy
over the throw that zack wilson made in
his pro day
and fields had some remarkable throws
athletic
ability on display it is pro day runs uh
rose
runs a 4 4 40. i mean what is going on
with him
it's entirely possible that that's the
guy that shanahan's identified too
wouldn't you say could it could be you
know i
i don't know but he is the guy who you
hear might drop a little bit
um i think it's going to be really
really interesting what if justin fields
is sitting there
let's say at 9 or 10. you know do the
patriots say
look let's let's stop fooling around and
and trade up to 10 or 11 and just get
justin fields even if it costs us next
year's one
uh and look i have no idea maybe chicago
would offer more than that
you know if if they'd be willing to go
down to 20 i don't know
but anyway i guess my overarching point
about justin fields is you know
i and again look i i wrote about dan
orlowski i got great regard for dan
orlowski i think he's
really really good uh analyst
and i just think he went too far with
his comments last week um
but but i but i will say this i will say
this
i don't know how you question the desire
of a guy who last year
became the point man for all players in
the big ten
to play got it got all these players to
sign a petition
uh for kevin winston that they wanted
the season to go on
safely and i don't know how you question
a guy's desire
when he takes as big a hit as he might
ever take
the rest of his football career misses
one
snap against clemson beats trevor
lawrence and throws touch
four touchdown passes the rest of the
way i you know so
so again you hear some things around
draft time
every year some things you just have to
say you know
i don't care if this is a guy i trust i
just simply don't buy it
and i am not buying that trevor lawrence
has got some
questionable desire or whatever to be
great
yeah i mean to me justin fields um
has got a tremendous amount of upside
and
i i don't know if it's an uh if it's an
ohio state thing uh because the last guy
that came out of ohio state and dwayne
haskins had some issues in the pros
uh and and it's just it again though the
the whole conversation you hear
um from evaluators um
and from what you're hearing and what
have you you have no idea
sometimes if that's somebody maybe in
the middle of the draft
who's trying to get someone to drop and
then they become you know
attached to the hip for years to come
and the player
because if i am calling someone
asking them for an opinion on it and
let's say
team x is picking 17th and
the the coach or scouter gm for team x
uh says hey i'm gonna plant with as many
as my buddies in the media
as i can that this guy is lazy and he
doesn't work and all that stuff and then
team x then's pick then picks justin
fields
let me let me just ask you this would
would any of those guys who he who he
planted that with
would they would they trust him about
anything
from here on out i know i wouldn't so i
know that that's a
popular conspiracy theorists uh
tool saying that uh it's a smoke screen
just to get you guys to
you know to to downgrade him i
i've not found that to be as common and
i'm not saying it never happens
but i'm not finding that that is as
common as some people think it is but i
mean
you you know i've been around some
combines um this year we didn't have one
so
there's been less of it peter i mean you
hear it from scouts who
might not even have a say in the room
you know what i'm saying and yeah so
so i'd understand that from an actual
grocery shopper saying that stuff i
wouldn't trust that person
again either but you hear agents you
hear all sorts of garbage
and and and that's why you rarely hear
an analyst
say what dan said publicly because you
know again
i don't want to source anything or
anything like that but
i guess we'll we'll find out um down
down the road here
but justin fields is not he's not going
to have a very long night in cleveland
ohio i don't think at all
i wouldn't think so i wouldn't think so
right but
i do think this rich every year
you know don't you think this year and i
just
talked to mel keiper for my for my
podcast this week
and and one of the things i i said to
him is don't you think this year
as much as ever that the quarterbacks
are getting pushed up the board yeah why
is that and some potentially
really great players obviously are
getting pushed down the board
right so that's why i think this draft
is
really going to be a lot of fun because
what if what if kyle pitts who
who some people think might be the best
tight end to ever come out in the draft
what if he gets picked 10th or 11th or
12th
i'm not saying he will i doubt he will
he might get picked
third or fourth or i mean fourth maybe
but but some things are going to happen
in this draft
that i think are gonna because everybody
is just
obsessed with the draft now i think some
things are gonna happen in this draft
that will take your breath away i can't
wait peter king
i can't wait um before i let you go
peter we're having a debate here on the
show
um would you rather if you knew your
team was going to lose the team you're
rooting for whether it is your alma
mater ohio or it's the red sox or
anything like that
and a team that you're emotionally
invested in if you knew that they were
going to lose
would you rather lose like houston did
over the weekend
in getting blown out by baylor or would
you rather lose like ucla where you were
in it you had a chance to knock off
potentially the eventual champion and
prevent that champion from
being undefeated you don't have to even
have to finish the question
absolutely like ucla and i'll just tell
you a quick story the last field hockey
game
my daughter mary beth played in uh
in new jersey they were in the state
semi-finals they were really really good
and they lost right at the end of the
game
and they went farther than anybody
thought
uh and and and they lost a heartbreaking
game and that night she's home she's
crying
and she's so sad and i just said to her
hey mary beth listen
you know all of your friends so many of
your friends
are sitting at home they're just they're
on the computer they're living their
life
they're they're fine they're happy
whatever and you are in
agony right now but you know what you
had you had
incredibly great moments with this team
in the playoffs this year in the state
playoffs plus you know you've had it
this way for four years playing this
sport that you love
so i mean aren't you happy that you had
those experiences
and it's like if i'm a ucla fan i mean
we were down by double digits in the
second half to michigan
state in a play-in game
we lost four straight before the
tournament we we weren't positive we
were getting in the tournament
and then we have all these incredible
games and play these overtime games and
win
that is what sports is about i know your
heart is broken today after getting that
shot that beat you but
what a game what an incredible game and
what a performance
you guys put on i absolutely
would rather lose in an agonizing
fashion peter appreciate that peter
aaron boone
brother like come on you don't want to
get ripped out
that's a little bit of a different story
no it's not it's the same
it's the same you're saying the reason
the reason that that's a different story
is that whole playoff thing with grady
little and pedro
that just pissed me off but his point is
would you rather just be loot down 10
nothing in the first and you don't have
any of that forever more that's what
he's wondering
but but if that was that would be we it
looks
the red stars lost that year because
they were horrendously
managed okay and so i
hey look that that night i was just
angry
if it was 11 nothing or if it's the
aaron boone walk off
i mean i don't care i just i just was so
angry about what what happened so anyway
despondent peter king sends us out the
door thanks for the call peter
i appreciate it we'll check it out
there's peter king
he made my point on your point too hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here